so i know it's been a minute but oh
it sure has but after a mid-season break
due to the pandemic
keeping up with the kardashians is about
to return in an explosive way
the trailer for the second half of
season 18 which dropped on monday
starts off with a very angry scott
disick
couldn't have been a bigger betrayal she
leaked me being there to the press
let's just focus on what's real and
what's happening then courtney's ex
and the father of her three kids hops on
a family zoom
and you'll never believe who makes a
surprise appearance
i don't trust anybody here no your eyes
are not deceiving you that really is rob
in the bottom right corner of your
screen
this is insane rob's doing great he
really is
i just want rob to do what's best for
him and what makes him happy the trailer
goes on to feature chloe having a pretty
intense conversation
with tristan thompson why couldn't you
be that when we were together
e.t recently reported that coco is back
together
with their basketball player beau and
that things have quote
been going really well a source told et
in may
that the parents of two-year-old true
have been isolating together
adding that the alone time has quote
really allowed them to reconnect
without outside influences i'm really
just enjoying my life
and my time with my baby and family but
back to the trailer
everybody in the world is talking about
coronavirus did chloe's time in
quarantine
also include her testing positive for
covid
i'm super worried that chloe's so sick
guests will have to wait to find out
you have to be really vulnerable and
it's emotional and
really really hard and if all that isn't
intense enough for you
he's doing a show in paris things are
escalating
paris might go on a lockdown we're gonna
have to leave courtney
we have to get out the clip ends with
kim
freaking out in paris truly leaving us
on the edge of our seats
holy sh last month the source confirmed
to et
that the show was back in production
after taking some time
off in june due to the pandemic at the
time the source explained that perk him
kanye's recent bipolar episode and his
struggle with mental health will not be
featured on the reality show
i've seen him go through a lot and he's
just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart
you